kamala harris has practically vanished
from the world stage since the
afghanistan debacle began despite
bragging about being the last person in
the room when the decision was made to
withdraw and talk about being tone deaf
the vp is still heading to vietnam of
all places this weekend as if the saigon
comparisons weren't enough for the
administration all this while her
approval rating continues to stay
underwater but that doesn't seem to
bother her
one bit shannon she was standing on the
stage wearing a mask kind of next to
president biden i'm sure that helped
hide her the look of disgust on her face
i assume what she was hearing well i
mean you point out the optics of her
going to vietnam could not be worse and
what we're told officially from the
administration is there will be no
travel plan changes for the vice
president but they have to know that
that could not possibly be worse for
them the images there but my thing is
that in this country there's so much
beauty of freedom for women that she
could rise to almost practically the
highest place in the country and yet her
voice we have not heard much from her
about what is now going to be the
reality for women and afghanistan and
girls being turned away from their jobs
being told to stay home we're told the
the council of islamic scholars is going
to decide whether they can go to school
or not i i just think we've got to wake
up to the reality of what's happening
there and listen women are mistreated in
many places around the country but
afghanistan it is showing in just
incredibly disgusting pictures day by
day i'd love to hear her voice as the
highest ranking female arguably in the
u.s to talk about what's going to happen
to them and how we can possibly right
the wrongs that are playing out right
now uh great oh but the state department
put out this statement a few days ago
paper you know words help and hurt i
guess this is how i can defend myself in
here in new york city since i'm not
allowed to carry a gun i can paper cuts
are so effective
tripp this is great i'd hide too yeah i
mean look she's going at saigon that
fell she's going to kabul that fell you
know just for giggles she should do a
layover in benghazi
now anyway uh so this is on again once
again i'm going to bash the media i know
that's rare but this is on the media and
the dems who didn't require much from
her since she had ticked all the right
intersectional boxes nobody liked her in
the party right she she didn't laugh she
was the first one out i think didn't
matter that she was untested and
unpopular she's a woman of color and
that trump in this case
competence personality effectiveness so
now what but that i think about the
democratic party man what are they
thinking they got they they they thought
they had a quarterback starting
quarterback and a backup quarterback
they have neither they got lemons they
got lemons and still she's closer to the
presidency than ever because you know
joe doesn't look that great and she's
keeping her distance from the uh the
whole afghan thing because she wasn't
part of it it's like a poop stick
anybody who touches it gets poop on them
yeah
jesse she's gonna have to take
i'm sorry i'm not i'm still
from that analogy
what is it
by the way i was gonna use the phrase
stick but no one would know i don't know
what a poop stick is it's a gob stick
it's
in the middle ages instead of toilet
paper okay
jessie don't know why i was thinking
about it you're always thinking about it
you're a medieval scholar
uh i'm medieval i'm no scholar
i'll just say they planned this
perfectly they were supposed to get out
of afghanistan she was supposed to go to
vietnam to reorient their whole strategy
towards the pacific and it blew right up
in their face now they're keeping the
trip scheduled because they're like we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
no they can't they can't do one thing at
once so she's gonna go and it's probably
good timing to get a little distance
literally and figuratively from joe
biden who's struggling right now so she
can go forge her own identity over in
vietnam and get a little space between
them and then come back in a couple
weeks and the dust may have settled but
she will have to do an interview when
she's there and she's going to be asked
on camera about afghanistan and that is
the test and the white house
communication shop is going to be
watching how is she going to handle it
is she going to have another huge gaffe
like she did with lester or is she going
to hug joe and try to keep things
together or maybe keep a little distance
for joe and say maybe i was warning she
doesn't have that gear you don't right
she's not talented enough to answer a
question on afghanistan so i predict a
huge foot in the mouth situation she
could do this
or the laugh voice but what you're
talking about doesn't exist no she can't
do either right so it's going to be as
greg said damaged goods
both of them she has a presser on monday
that's going to be a
blast
richard
wow look i i listen
criticism against joe biden warranted
absolutely he deserves to take it on the
chin for how he exited afghanistan i'm
not going to walk away from that
people being mad at kamala harris the
vice president who didn't make the
decision is unbelievable whoa she said
she was the last person yes but she
she's she couldn't be the last person in
the room but the person whose name the
buck stops with the president of the
united states and it's it'd be the same
as saying
donald trump made a mistake or donald
trump tweeted and we're blaming mike
pence for that tweet and i think that's
also it's unwarranted unfair now should
she
wait did mike pence sign off on the
tweet though because she said she was in
the room the last person with him and
that she was part of this policy
fair but once again if you're going to
heap criticism on anybody you keep
criticism on the person who is the
president of the united states the
person who's actually the
commander-in-chief for us to be doing a
segment about kamala harris and blaming
her for what happened in afghanistan
that exit i think is a little bit unfair
no one's blaming her it just has the
stench of failure wafting over to her
hair
and she's number two and bobby was the
placeholder right remember the
placeholder richard i guess she's
plotting
no
if you want to blame joe biden for this
absolutely i did i did and so did you
they need to keep her away from him so
she doesn't get stained right and so
that she can inherit i'll end on this
how many times
did the media
chatter boxes or any democrats say where
is pence yes where's pence in all this
when trump would say or do something did
they have a calendar for melania
and while we're talking about women from
california the one woman of california
who deserves praise is barbara lee who
voted against this war from the
beginning
the woman who is the vice president
is briefed regularly on the unfolding
situation in afghanistan so
maybe she can stand in front of the
american people and not lie
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else